[Music]
hello everyone well my name is Patrick
clay and I'm an engineer working on
Google Cloud Data proc I'm here today to
demonstrate to you how you can use
Apache spark ml lib on Google Cloud Data
proc to gain insight your data to train
models and then to deploy those into
production I know that you've heard a
lot about machine learning on the Google
cloud platform or the past couple days
but I hope by the end of this you will
walk away thinking that spark and melody
is a tool that you should be excited
about and consider trying if you haven't
already my talk will primarily be a demo
of spark a melon on Google Cloud a of
rock but before that I want to introduce
the tools I'll be using the demo not
just ml lid and data proc by bigquery
and cloud data lab and at the end I'll
try to wrap things up and make
comparisons to our new suite of machine
learning offerings so before I dive into
this just so I can have a sense of the
audience can I see a show of hands who
has used the tools that I just mentioned
I'll mention again who's used bigquery
ok quite a few M's cloud data lab couple
data proc Jena couple and Apache spark
either on data progress or okay that's a
lot yes that's why you're here
so doesn't need too much of an
introduction based on your hands but
victory is the oldest and possibly most
popular data processing tool on our
cloud it's our one-stop data warehouse
and sequel engine and it's best use case
is scaling your queries from megabytes
to terabytes
even the petabytes if you need without
ever worrying about configuring
resources setting indexes
scales as you need I so I like to think
of as interactive speed that when you're
in the big gray console you can just
write a query and before you have to
switch tabs certainly before you have to
walk down the hall to get a coffee your
query runs however the world isn't all
sequel and sometimes you want to do
things like machine learning so that's
where Cloud Data lab comes in data lab
adds a bunch of rich features to Google
Cloud sis storage services like bigquery
so it can take data from cloud sequel
cloud storage big thang weary and then
process that data inside of a Jupiter
based cloud notebook with all of your
favorite Python beta processing
libraries pandas numpy sci-fi can also
process them on cloud distributed
processing engines like data flow data
proc or now ml engine if you want to do
machine running inside of cloud data lab
attempt to flow and scikit-learn
and there's really nice visualizations
ok so we're here to talk about power I'm
here to talk about Apache spark which I
think combines a lot of the best aspects
of bigquery and data lab my view you
might think of Apache spark as just a
general distributed processing engine on
the JVM like a Hadoop MapReduce but
maybe a little more memory optimized
maybe a little more higher level like
Apache beam and that's all true but
really in the last two years spark has
tried to differentiate itself by adding
layers on top of its base processing
engine the first being spark sequel and
I really like spark sequel because I
like processing in sequel I like data
frames and Python I like using the
pandas library or numpy so I when I'm
using spark I almost entirely use some
form of start sequel
ml lid the machine learning library I'm
here to talk about is now currently
almost entirely based on spark speak
well so if you can write sequel if you
can use data frames you can use AM L web
ml lib like I said it's a machine
learning library safety I was inspired
by scikit-learn and it is many many
machine learning algorithms it has kind
of all of your classics linear in
logistic regression k-means clustering
as kind of your workhorse algorithms
like random forests or symbol vector
machines and even some esoteric
algorithms like blatantly relay analysis
or allocation rather but there's more to
machine learning than running algorithms
you have to convert your data from
whatever form you find it into
standardized features and this is
another place where ml Lib shines
because it's based on spark and spark is
first and foremost a data processing
engine so it's really simple to take raw
X data convert it into initially numeric
data and then vectorize data all those
transformations are built in very easy
to use once you have your
transformations and your algorithms
compress them together and the
pipeline's
if you run the Train models and then you
can improve the models with high
performance tuning and I will show you
all that in the demo
unfortunately spark can be a little
painful to use it requires at the very
least a cluster of machines which fuel
compute engine can provide but then you
have to install the software configure
it all these things so that's where
Google Cloud Data proc comes in the
product I work on and it provides a
fully managed cluster running Apache
spark that's you do Peggy and hive and
on top of these it adds cloud storage
file system so that you can keep all of
your data and GCS
don't have to worry about maintaining
your cluster and bigquery connector for
structured data one of the kind of the
lesser known features of Cloud Data proc
is being able to mix in many different
things but certainly cloud notebooks so
I reimagined data lab there's also
patching Zeppelin which came out of the
spark community and Jupiter the original
notebook as it were which worked really
well with spark because spark is so
memory optimized that just like bigquery
if you're sitting in that interactive
cloud notebook environment you just run
a couple lines of code and see your
results within seconds data proc is
really fast you can give it if you want
at end node cluster and have it in under
two minutes you decide 10 to the 10 VMs
is enough and I 100 VM another two
minutes the configuration means it's
really easy to use you just say I'd like
a cluster if you want two more
configuration you can do that and lastly
and most importantly it's ephemeral so
all of your data stays kind of cloud
storage service and you don't have to
worry about it so how does this all fit
together so that's quite pale but the
data lab runs inside of a docker
container on a compute engine VM inside
of the data proc cluster data lab uses
Sparx Python PI spark AP is to access op
spark across all the nodes of the
cluster and both spark and data lab
access Google cloud services such as
cloud storage and bakery the user
accesses data lab just as they normally
would run running on GCE so that further
ado let's switch to the demo show this
so this as most of you who raised your
hands should recognize is big gray and I
today I will be looking at the New York
City Taxi and Limousine Commission
yellow taxicab data sets it's one of my
favorite public data sets on Google
cloud we have quite a few mostly on
bigquery which you can see here some in
Google Cloud storage and now some on
pub/sub if you saw the keynote yesterday
you saw a demo of using bigquery data
flow and ml engine to analyze people who
are coming from airports and near food
for advertising purposes it's quite
slick I'm today I'm not interested in
such a specific question I have a broad
question where are people in New York
catching taxi cabs specifically where it
specifically on a at a given time on a
given day of a week we're in New York
our taxi cab pickups happening so I
don't need this entire data set which is
why which makers I will run this query
to filter out only to only select the
pickups and it's important that I
filtered this data because if you when I
swing in bigquery is you can preview
your data and you'll notice that there's
a lot of problematic entries and any
data set but certainly a free data set
as all these zeros I don't want to train
my model on a taxi cab pickups off the
coast of West Africa so clean my model
and put it in this text cab data set
which will fee so as a billion records
even after that filtering and we need
somewhere to process this so I will use
my terminal to spin up a data processor
normally I would use the cloud console
to spin it up and most of the but not
all these legs are available this is a
20 node cluster because why not I can
scale out and lose the initialization
action which is like a dual compute
starter script except you can specify
more than one of them in this particular
one insult data lab you can specify both
of those inside of the cloud console but
I a JavaScript issue with one my
libraries so I am using a I'm telling we
start the initialization actually use a
different docker image than normal but
essentially just regularly running the
initialization action so data lab when
running on GCE opens a web server a web
UI inside of the cluster and I need to
be able to access that from outside the
cluster so our suggested way of doing
that is to SSH into the cluster and
create an SSH tunnel
you could also open parts in your
firewall but that's considered less
secure and so I do this instead and now
and yet another terminal I too many
terminals I can open a special Google
Chrome that is configured to use this
proxy and where is that oh that's on my
other screen and I bring that over and
so I can still find my first terminal
we're still deploying the cluster so it
takes two minutes capable more than two
minutes of running initialization
actions there we go so now hopefully
together welcome to de lab very
important notes a de lab is no longer
beta just doesn't apply anymore
data lab went GA this week are generally
available but like I said I was using an
old docker image you can load notebooks
in your data lab a number of ways but
I'm just going to load one from my
machine since I upload my Python
notebook
and we'll click on it hopefully okay
this is the data lab notebook if you're
at all familiar with Jupiter or Zeppelin
or even MATLAB or Mathematica you'll be
familiar with these cell kind of
notebook things the first thing I'm
going to do kind of as a preamble is to
install a Google Maps visualization
library that I'll use later but I wanted
to do that get that out of the way and
not a good sign oh there we go
all good and just really reload so loads
of JavaScript okay on to the rest so the
first thing you have to do when data
processing in SPARC is load data and
it's not glamorous so I'm just going to
try and get it all the way at once but
you can see that data lab has provided
very convenient Google Cloud storage and
bigquery library or AP is that allowed
me to extract the table that I just
created in bigquery as compressed CSV
and Google Cloud storage and when that
finishes we will be able to load it into
spark and because we're using spark
sequel and data frames we can just infer
the schema from that csv record okay
that there's a bug and the gates don't
get parts correctly so I have to do
manual date processing oh there we go so
I printed out the schema of my my data
frame and you can see that the date
column written here is a string so now
I'm converting it to a state in SPARC
not at all interesting and not related
to ml lib now I'm just previewing my
data one great thing about SPARC is that
you don't actually have to load all of
your data and at all to preview it you
can just look at a tiny piece so that's
what we've done here all right I should
have actually asked before is this
legible in the back all right good
and so you see now we have a nice when
the taxi was picked up where it was
picked up somewhere in New York in the
lat/long in data lab we can run queries
against bigquery also in SPARC you can
register sequel you can register sequel
tables so I'm just running a simple
select account star against both
bigquery and SPARC to make sure that I
have all the data it takes a long time
in spark because the state is still
sitting in GCS SPARC is lazy so until I
say select count star it will actually
never load the data once that finishes
what I want to do is I need to bucket my
data into the hour and day of the week
so that I know so I can ask the question
on a typical Thursday morning at 10:00
a.m.
how many taxi cabs were there in New
York City and so this sequel query just
buckets my data by hour day a week
and city block essentially one
thousandth of a GPS coordinate sorry of
a degree of latitude or longitude so you
can see we haven't lost me data we have
all the records and we can start a few
learning that needs to run and oh that's
the we're in well that's running I'd
like to introduce to spark ml live API
this emilybs API is actually my favorite
thing about it beyond its convenience in
its use because I think it's really
slick there are four main classes in a
melody transformers which take data and
output new data really what they do is
they all add a column to your data frame
so just add a column to your equal pay
structure there estimators which take
your data frame and output a trained
model so these are all the algorithms I
mentioned the regressors the classifiers
the clusters then there's the model
itself which takes your data and makes
predictions based on it and the really
neat thing is predictions are just
another column of data and I said
transformers or things that take your
data and add a column so models are
transformers which means you can compose
them in just a sequence of Transformers
and then estimator you fit it to get a
model and you keep transforming the way
that you compose them the best way is
inside a pipeline and here's a picture
from this is just from the spark
documentation you can find it just spark
ml pipeline but setting taxis aside for
a second suppose you had some raw text
like say the works of Shakespeare and
you wanted to classify them into say
categories comedies tragedies etc one
way you could go about this is you take
your raw text
you've split it into words or possibly
engrams depending on your model then you
need to somehow convert these words into
some kind of numerical feature vector
and then finally you train them an
estimator on that so in this case spark
provides just plug and play a tokenizer
many different things but a hashing
transform and the logistic regression
estimator you put all of these together
in a pipeline and then you fit the
pipeline and you end up with your train
model that you can transform into
predictions so this is again straight AB
sparks ap documentation but the high
level is we create toy code but it has
this text column we define these
transforms and estimators all in like
one line of code and throw them together
into a pipeline fit it to our data we
get a model you run the model or you
create toy test data and then you
transform the model to get predictions
so really this is in this case it's a
very glorified word count the data is
designed so that spark is if the data
contains the word spark it's 1 otherwise
it's a zero but in general you could do
more fancy transformations like topic at
determination in the Shakespeare example
so if I scroll back up the last thing I
said when I pre process data was that
I'd like to describe it I know this top
column is quite faint but here's the
final state of our data there's the hour
in which the data the hour in the day
between 0 and 23 which it was picked up
the day of the week one being Monday 7
being Sunday and our latitude and
longitude pocket-sized
surrounded to the thousands the count of
the number of
pick ups in this region and then just
because it's kind of unreasonable to
train a model from 1 to 5,000 I took the
log of that so it's between 0 and 11
which is more manageable so now instead
of so now let's actually do some machine
learning so this should look very
similar to the text processing example
except we don't need to do much
transformation because I chose to use a
random forced regressor and one of the
wonderful things about random forests is
they don't require much pre-processing
they can take numeric data
they don't need normalized or
categorical or fancy transformations
which spark MLM can all do what so all I
do is take the columns that I'm
interested in I put them in a vector
called features I tell the regressor
look at the features and try to predict
the label column which is that log space
feature column and run predictions and
if I run that now
we get some predictions so some of these
are pretty good there's only one pickup
here you predict you the very low amount
this is pretty perfect one for one but
some of them are pretty not-so-great
like this one so let's be more specific
I mention evaluators in my ml classes
but they're also very important so you
can take the evaluator and find that our
our squared value is about 1/2 and our
root mean squared error is about one and
a half so in layman's terms mean the
root mean squared error means that
logarithmic space were off by usually
about fifty percent so if there were six
passengers we might think there's
between four and nine which isn't too
bad or sorry that's expositors six taxis
leaving in that hour but I still don't
have a great sense of how good or bad
our model is so what I'm going to do is
rely on cloud data labs visualization
capabilities and sample both the real
data and simulated data where the
simulated data takes the number of
pickups we predicted and randomly
generates them inside that bucket so
this is the Google Maps library that I
load at the beginning and it forms a
very nice Google map
heat map so this is what we predict
during my scroll rush-hour at Thursday
we seem to have found Manhattan which is
good but we have a lot of pickups in the
middle of East River and it's generally
kind of messy if you compare this to the
real data you'll see this is very nice
and pretty because that's what the real
data is it's all on the streets
LaGuardia is all nice so clearly we have
some work to do we can also look at the
middle of the night again on a Thursday
and we it really is no better whereas
reality is again quite nice and Queen
also in real life less people are
catching taxis in the middle of the
night on a Thursday but we didn't really
learn that so how do we improve our
model so every estimator but also pretty
much every class in the ml lid has this
extract program map method where you can
look at the parameters inside of it so
this is what our random forest regressor
ran within the default parameters I'll
draw your attention to the trees are
only of depth five trees are only of
depth five and there were twenty of them
not much of a forest and not much in
terms of trees so we could go and rerun
the code with a deeper tree or more
trees but then we have to worry about
overtraining and all of these things so
really the trick is to what spark do the
work for you and set up a perimeter grid
and say please consider trees of depth 5
and 15 and trees of 5 and and set the
number of trees to both 5 and 20 build
this whole grid and then evaluate it
there are a couple different ways to run
all of your grid I use a chain
validation split you could also use
cross-validation it's not a big deal
this is one case where Sparks does take
a long time which is why I kicked off
all my data processing beforehand
cross-validation takes a long time
because as a general rule spark will
never transform the same data twice at
the same time and so unfortunately when
you run your parameter grid it will only
ever use one it'll only ever use one
piece of the grid at a time and if
you've scaled out as I have it's pretty
fast but it's still not great
so with this I took the best model and
evaluated it on my validation data and
we got a better r-squared about 7/3 not
not the best but our root mean squared
error is now getting aa more reasonable
and if we go back and look at our models
we can reese immolate the data and now
this kind of looks respectable we don't
have pick up from the middle of the East
River
usually we had picked up to LaGuardia
okay that was bad
it's to the 6p anyways but we found
Manhattan much better and it looks much
more like the real data same with
midnight we still think that there are
more pickups than there are but at least
they're at reasonable locations and for
the sake of time I didn't set a huge
parameter grid or super deep trees but
if you train on all the data with super
deep trees or trees of depth 30 which is
the deepest part goes you can get up
above 90 percent all right an hour
squared value of over 0.95 I kind of
glossed over splitting the data into
test validation and training but I did
and here's the actual test results and
they're exactly in line with our
validation which is good we didn't over
fit our model and pretty much everything
I've done here could be done on any
spark cluster on GC assuming you had one
but I'm the last great thing about a
melody is the ability to take models and
reuse them later
so if you've seen talks on ml engine and
version models of certain laws in the
cloud this isn't exactly that but
somewhat similar in that we can take the
model that we just trained I don't even
know what this model is it's the best
model that bag grid put out and write it
out to GCS and take our and take any
data but in this case our test data
right that also out to cloud storage and
then after tearing down our cluster in
another cluster a year from now we can
just load the model load our data run
our predictions write them out to in to
write them out again evaluate them do
whatever we like and at least these four
are completely agnostic as to what we
did in our data processing all I know is
that I made a spark ml led pipeline but
these four lines of code are absolutely
reusable over and over again and to
demonstrate that so I go back to one of
my crew go back to one my terminals
actually if I go back to my other chrome
browser I have this file in GCS called
predictive high and just does those four
lines load a model load some data can
form the data using the model to make
predictions save that out to cloud
storage again and I can submit this as a
once again and I can submit this as a
job to cloud data rocket using the jobs
API
and the jobs API if you view spark this
is essentially the same as earning
sparks a bit on a Python application
there's too much log stamps that I
should filter out but oh and I'm running
on actually I was running that on the
same cluster I'm entering that on a
different cluster to demonstrates that I
don't need to know about anything that
went on in that cluster this is entirely
separate cluster you can't really see
that but it is and seria and now it will
take that data transform it write those
predictions out and you could use those
predictions somewhere else so if you
were using cloud data lab or any
notebook generate a model an interactive
kind of ad hoc exploratory way you can
save that model send it off to another
engineer another team doesn't matter use
that model over and over again and that
is really a lot of log spin but it says
right there
with predictions so I can which was be
all done successful job and that's all I
have in the demo so if we go back to the
slides okay to wrap things up
hopefully you just saw a spark on data
proc can leverage sparks equal to do
very useful kind of ad hoc data
processing ml lib to take that data
processing and add very simple three
line machine learning API is on top of
that when you use it with data lab you
get that interactive just run run go
back and edit your parameters options or
you can use grid tune parameter grids so
you don't have to and that beautiful
visualization of Google Maps Google
charts and other things and lastly with
the data probes API you can take all of
your train models and reuse them
elsewhere
so I promised I'd talk about other
machine learning offerings compare and
contrast them so what about cloud ml
engine it's similar to ML live in many
respects you chain your models in the
distributed fashion you can persist the
models for later use and the high level
API of tensorflow if you went to the
talks there one of the high level API is
it's called TF join both TF learn and ml
lib are both based on scikit-learn so a
lot of the estimator model that should
all feel pretty similar between the two
there are some differences but it should
be pretty much the same however they do
each have key strings M L engine was
written for tensorflow
it is tensorflow so it's tensorflow was
written first and foremost for deep
wedding so if you want deep learning
highly recommend tense fluent ml engine
spark does have deep learning they do
over neural Nets but it's been or ml it
does but it's been it's not it's
intended for cloud purpose ml engine is
serverless sure you've heard that word a
lot recently data proc is not data crock
you don't have I mean you don't have to
maintain a server you can swim without
take one down but you do have GCE VMs
and there's advantages to both ways one
of the advantage of being server list is
a user with a cell phone can reclines on
a cell phone can make a call to the
prediction API you don't have to worry
about managing infrastructure at all the
advantage of having the cluster around
is you can have your data cache in
memory and spark you can do that kind of
ad hoc iterative exploratory analysis
furthermore you can do the kind of
general spark processing or
pre-processing on your data so all that
kind of painful sequel munging ideas
beginning you could do in dataflow or
spark and beam and then run on ml engine
but it's all sitting there for you with
spark I'm David Brock and the last key
advantage are already mentioned the
interactive speed with a cache memory
the last key advantage of a melody is
that all VAP eyes have ten parameters
you don't need to specify them they work
out of the box you can auto zoom them
and they can be written like the four
lines of code that I showed the very end
the last similarity that I didn't
mention when I was mentioned with
similarities is that both are built on
open source so the keynote today there
was a lot of talk about how tensor flows
in many respects one of the hottest
open-source projects out there right now
certainly if you look at github
statistics when I checked spark and
tensorflow
are the two most fourth github projects
so they're both very similar in that
respect and they're both still giving
incredible amount of commits tends to
flow just on one dot o spark went to die
last summer but is continuing to iterate
and evolve so it's kind of really an
exciting time to be using either tool
and with ml engine and data proc you
constantly leverage all the improvements
that are being driven in both
communities that's essentially all I
have if I've encouraged you to go try
any of this out I have some helpful
links my demo is not available on any of
these links but it will be at some point
these slides will be available I believe
and the the demo should be linkable
through one of the quick starts there in
the cloud data park quick starts to be
also tutorials the initialization
actions including the data lab one I
demoed there's resources on spark ml and
cloud data lab and lastly for the New
York City Taxi data set
if you and you can go and look up our
version of it but if you just google New
York City Taxi data set can find lots of
great and interesting other data science
projects that people have leveraged it
for and that might inspire you these
links are also possibly helpful if you
get stuck on any of the the quick starts
they're mostly data practice if ik
because they write to me the stack
overflow also has the Apache spark
Cannella
[Music]
[Music]